seems like neither team could knock a
shot down a lot of turnovers because
both teams so excited opening night is
here
[Applause]
duck curry again in the corner and at a
wild surive considered you student 7
before sweeping the Cavaliers and frozen
state of shift 6 of its first second
from the field on jiske 43 how the NCAA
has changed to be in the first corner
already surely granted just came out and
there's no one behind Adams on that
plays Lodi never been in that position
terrific season
[Applause]
but I'm surprised people around the NBA
by reciting with the oklahoma city mark
i sat down with paul and he not only
addressed the reciting but then
[Applause]
the Oklahoma City 21st overall be enjoy
the lush green this is gonna have to
keep letting it fly that's what he's
here for you can't get shot so well and
it's a two-point game
curry double team gets it's a living
Alice having that third ball handler in
this
[Music]
and right now Jones burning his way into
this game show skinny shallow hole
two-point game with a minute and 50
remaining over for glory